jerusalem zu diesem song tanzen 2020
weltweit tausende wie diese schüler aus
hamburg
ärzte und pflegepersonal aus düsseldorf
privatpersonen beim corsa lena flashmob
flughafenangestellte aus riga sogar
priester und nonnen in italien
dieses video aus angola gehörte zu den
ersten
nachdem die tanzgruppe es online
gestellt hatte wurde der song zum
millionen klicks und die weltweite dance
challenge war geboren
der frankfurter tanz choreograf und
coach kilic e.on jehle war vom ersten
augenblick an selbst inspiriert von dem
song
er erklärt sich das phänomen jerusalemer
so sondern im song ist dass die saison
sehr spirituell ist auch der song ist
von den menschen aus dass sie mut
kriegen dass die energie kriegen dass
sie kraft kriegen dass sie gerade jetzt
eine pandemie zeit die wir haben
dass man sagt ich lasse mir alle sorgen
kurz beiseite nehmen wir mal kurz zeit
für mich und meine mitmenschen meine
kollegen chef
egal wir alles nur eins in alle verein
sich in diesem tanz jerusalemer ist die
bekannteste dance trance in diesem jahr
aber sind nicht die einzige auf
plattformen wie tik tok entdecken viele
im lockdown das tanzen für sie in europa
und auf der ganzen welt gehen zahlreiche
choreografin viral tänze zum song
blending likes von beginnt führen
den erfolgreichsten
[Musik]
auch zu let's do it again von jake wird
2020 in europa und weltweit geteilt
hier kam center von snoop dogg und eine
kendrick ist gegen ende des jahres sehr
beliebt karachi an jene zeit worauf es
bei der choreografie von james l emma
ankommt die formel dafür herausgefunden
habe sehr schwer ist
6 x 46 x 4 schritte macht man ganz
einfach 123 41 24 dann kommt der wechsel
schritt und so sieht es aus wenn sich
viele menschen in der korona zeit einen
gemeinschaftsgefühl hingeben in europa
und weltweit
die messe ist von diesem song ganz klar
es geht nur zusammen
gerade in dieser schwierigen zeit nehmen
ist und auch gerade dann wenn man auch
kritisch ist es geht einfach immer
zusammen das macht einfach so viel mehr
spaß wenn man sich zusammenschließt egal
welche hautfarbe religion familienstand
egal was du im leben erreicht hatten was
nicht es geht zusammen und zwar mit
einfachen mitteln man bewegt sich
zusammen
die motion kommt vom motion das ist es
was die tausenden teilnehmer der
jerusalemer benz challenge mit ihren
videos erlebt und geschaffen haben ein
bisschen leichtigkeit freude und vor
allem gemeinschaftsgefühl in diesem ganz
besonderen jahr